c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
soyez les bienvenus sur france 24 à la
une ce soir le spectre de la guerre
civile qui plane de nouveau sur la libye
48 heures après des affrontements à
tripoli qui ont fait 32 morts depuis le
processus électoral avortée de décembre
2021 le premier ministre sortant abdel
hamid bébé est le nouveau fait fi bachar
a désigné par le parlement se disputent
le pouvoir décryptage dans un instant
avec hasni abidi politologue et
spécialiste du maghreb et du
moyen-orient
le recomptage des voix dans 15 bureaux
de vote au kenya une demande de
l'opposant raila odinga ils contestent
la victoire à la présidentielle de son
rival williams bhutto nous serons
anaérobie dans ce journal
et à la fin de cette édition nous irons
en tunisie où plus de 200 festival se
sont tenus cet été une bouffée d'oxygène
après la crise sanitaire les tunisiens
et surtout les plus jeunes étaient ravis
reportage à suivre
la libye risque t'elle de sombrer de
nouveau dans le chaos les événements de
ces dernières 48 heures laisse en tout
cas à présager le pire de violents
combats ont secoué tripoli ce week end
le bilan fait état de 32 morts des
affrontements provoqués par la rivalité
entre deux hommes l'ancien premier
ministre abdelhamid bébé est le nouveau
désigné par le parlement fathi basharat
le conseil de sécurité de l'onu se
réunit ce mardi pour débattre de la
situation en libye pour en parler nous
sommes en direct avec hasni abidi
politologue et spécialiste du maghreb et
du moyen-orient bonsoir ce n'est habité
merci d'être avec nous bonsoir alors la
situation en libye et est très
inquiétante risque-t-elle de dégénérer
oui la situation est très inquiétant
parce qu'on assiste à un blocage et on
est passé d'un blocage de la les
processus politiques haïle crise 5
grammes dans la mesure où vous avez un
gouvernement qui est désigné par le
parlement de tobrouk à l'est qui veut
prendre la place du gouvernement de
monsieur bemba qui normalement le
gouvernement qui a reçu une certaine
légalité ou une acceptabilité
internationale il a tenté de faire déjà
une fois on bars il n'a pas réussi la
deux une fois avec la force et on a bien
vu qu'il y avait des rivalités encore
pour la première fois entre des
fractions certaine fraction qui
soutiennent à mes pays bas et d'autres
qui soutient patrick buchard à une
devant le chaos généralisé dans
plusieurs quartiers à tripoli flash a
soutenu par le conte de l'est d'après
viable que tout se retirer alors qui est
responsable de cette escalade
obtenir que les deux ses responsables
flett babe a apparemment fait les bevara
insiste sur le fait qu'il a plutôt le
parlement derrière lui il sens et une à
mon avis le parlement de l'est qui hisse
la coupe d'artois prend une
responsabilité importante et messieurs
de bahebeck qui continue entre le chef
de gouvernement qui prépare les
élections mais son processus
d'organisation des élections
législatives et présidentielles et l'a
déjà échoué une fois parce qu'il faut
que je me rappelle que ces élections ont
joué moi dont les comptes étaient prévus
mois de décembre il ya une
responsabilité collective parce que la
fois à l'est et à l'ouest on a échoué à
élaborer quel sera le projet en tout cas
la loi et déploie et le processus qui va
organiser ces élections qui sont censés
être vraiment d'assortir le ce blocage
voulait dire alors abdelhamid ben hiba
parle d'ingérence de pays extérieurs on
connaissait l'implication de la turquie
et du qatar au clan de file sa rage et
de l'egypte et des émirats de l'arabie
saoudite auprès du maréchal haftar qu'en
est il aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est
toujours aussi clair
tous ces acteurs que vous avez cités
sont toujours présents ils n'auront pas
abandonner la salle libyenne il ya les
changements d'alliances lorsqu'au bâclé
bachar a quitté lui qui de misrata est
qui et qui tu es plutôt proche du
gouvernement de tripoli à changer
d'alliance aujourd'hui il est proche
plus tôt deux présidents des parlements
de l'est et évidemment il garde de
bonnes relations à la fois avec le caire
mais aussi avec en quarts donc il ya ici
c'est une configuration qui est mouvante
et qui est instable on peut dire
qu'aujourd'hui la turquie a joué un rôle
important en étant présente sur le plan
militaire
elle a joué son rôle de repoussoir
contre toute tentative de
déstabilisation de hamid belkhir est
beaucoup plus proche de carlo janka
alors très rapidement une réunion se
tient ce mardi au conseil de sécurité de
l'onu autour de la situation en libye
que faut-il en attendre
pas grand chose parce qu'il n'y a pas de
consensus au sein de conseil de sécurité
le conseil de sécurité va rappeler la
nécessité d'organiser de nouvelles
élections
la nécessité aussi à ce que les deux
instances puisse se mettre d'accord pour
organiser ces élections c'est important
mais encore une fois la solution aller
libyenne elle doit absolument venir d'un
sursaut libyen pour enfin se doter
d'institutions accepté par de lui bien
merci beaucoup à ce n'est à médire
politologue et spécialiste du maghreb et
du moyen-orient merci pour votre
décryptage on en vient la création la
réaction pardon mitigé des leaders
politiques guinéens après leur rencontre
avec le médiateur désigné de la cedeao
l'ancien président béninois thomas yayi
boni a rencontré à conakry les
militaires au pouvoir et le nouveau
premier ministre il a aussi échangé avec
la classe politique guinéenne qui lui a
soumis des revendications la
correspondance de manif diakité
toutes les rencontres avaient été menés
à huis clos entre thomas boni yayi
médiateur de la cedeao et les
différentes coalitions politiques du
pays la nada l'alliance nationale pour
l'alternance démocratique une coalition
qui soutient cellou dalein diallo le rpg
arc en ciel du président dessus alpha
condé et la branche politique du fn
décès de sidya touré ont été reçus
ensemble par thomas boni yayi et lui ont
remis un mémorandum avec leurs
revendications et exigences pour leur
participation à un dialogue avec les
militaires au pouvoir nous avons demandé
au médiateur le faire tôt possible pour
que les autorités arrêtent
l'arrestation arbitraire
nous avons demandé aussi au médiateur
aujourd'hui les principaux ont été
imposées au peuple de guinée nous voyons
aussi qu' il y a des leaders par les
moindres qui sont exilés pour de quoi
parce qu'il ya parlé justice du côté de
la coalition des partis politiques pour
une alternance démocratique on sollicite
la cedeao pour accompagner les
militaires au pouvoir nous l'avons
demandé de l'assemblée nous l'avons
demandé d'appeler tout le monde on
dialogue nous l'avons demandé d'aider le
cnrd à réussir cette transition
nous l'avons demandé de sensibiliser
les présidents de la cedeao n'est pas
sanctionné notre pays car quand les
sanctions tombent la population et la
plume hier a soufflé le rapport au final
de la cedeao concernant ces
consultations est très attendue par la
classe politique
la communauté économique des états
d'afrique de l'ouest of favorable à une
courte transition a déjà rejeté les
trois ans de transition proposée par le
pouvoir du colonel mamadou doumbouya
on en parlait dans ce journal le 20 août
dernier l'ex première dame de côte
d'ivoire simone ehivet gbagbo a créé son
parti politique le mouvement des
générations capables ce mardi dans une
interview exclusive accordée à marc
perelman elle s'est exprimée sur sa
potentielle candidature à l'élection
présidentielle de 2000 25 pour elle rien
n'était exclu j'ai écouté j'ai dit que
si mon parti il décide que je suis la
personne la mieux placée en tant que
présidente du parti pour
débattre à ce niveau là donc je le ferai
je n'ai aucune difficulté à pour cela
mais si le parti décide qu'il faut
quelqu'un d'autre eh bien j'ai ma ligne
e à ce que le parti décidera c'est une
méthode très disciplinés vous avez voilà
pour cette interview que vous pourrez
retrouver sur notre site internet
rubrique entretien le navire de l'espoir
il s'appelle le brave comme en 2e et il
transporte 23 mille tonnes de nourriture
vers l'ethiopie de la nourriture
destinée à des millions de personnes
souffrent de la faim le bateau est
arrivé ce mardi matin au port de
djibouti
le nord de l'ethiopie subi une profonde
crise humanitaire causée par un conflit
qui dure depuis novembre 2001 laurent
vers stecher
après deux semaines en mer le bref comme
under est arrivé à bon port à bord 23
mille tonnes de blé ukrainien qui
devrait soulager une partie des besoins
alimentaires en ethiopie
la nourriture transportés par ce navire
permettra de nourrir un million et demi
de personnes pendant un mois en ethiopie
cela a donc un impact très important
pour ces gens qui n'ont actuellement
la cargaison du navire doit maintenant
être acheminés depuis djibouti vers
l'ethiopie où la sécheresse les conflits
et l'effondrement économique font planer
l'ombre de la famille
lundi les nations unies faisaient une
nouvelle fois part de leurs inquiétudes
face à la crise dans un pays plongé dans
une violente guerre civile depuis près
de deux ans
la situation humanitaire dans le nord de
l'ethiopie reste extrêmement
préoccupante
nous appelons encore une fois toutes les
parties du conflit immédiatement
autoriser l'acheminement d'air et de
personnels humanitaires vers le
face à l'urgence l'onu avait oeuvré le
mois dernier pour la signature entre
kiev et moscou d'un accord permettant à
trois ports ukrainiens de reprendre les
exportations de céréales mais l'arrivée
du bref comme entre djibouti et loin de
résoudre tous les problèmes dans la
corne de l'afrique une région où le
programme alimentaire mondial estime que
80 2 millions de personnes ont besoin
d'aidé alimentaire
raïla odinga a remporté une bataille
l'opposant kenyan qui conteste la
victoire de son rival à la
présidentielle williams bhutto a obtenu
le recomptage de 15 bureaux de vote et
l'accès aux serveurs de la commission
électorale les précisions de notre
correspondant à nairobi bastien vos
nuits
c'est un premier point positif pour le
parti à ginola ou modja de raïla odinga
depuis l'annoncé des résultats de cette
élection présidentielle il le demande
ils vont pouvoir recompter les voix de
15,8 dans 15 bureaux de vote différents
afin de s'assurer que les résultats qui
ont été décomptés sur place correspond
bien aux résultats qui ont été annoncés
par la commission électorale ici à
nairobi lors de ce décompte ils seront
accompagnés de membre du parti uba de
william ou tôt afin de s'assurer qu'ils
soient d'accord quant aux nombres qui
seront annoncés et ils seront encadrés
par la police afin de s'assurer qu'il
n'y ait pas de débordements le parti a
gigolo modja va aussi avoir accès aux
serveurs de la commission électorale il
dénonce un piratage qui aurait pu
aboutir à des changements de formulaires
ce qui aurait faussé le résultat de
cette élection présidentielle ils vont
pouvoir analyser ces données et auront
jusqu'à jeudi 14h pour annoncer leurs
conclusions à la cour suprême une cour
suprême qui prendra ses conclusions en
compte dans sa délibération elle aura
jusqu'au 5 septembre pour annoncer son
verdict en tunisie la saison des
festivals d'été vient de s'achever avec
près de 250 événements à travers le pays
cette reprise après deux ans de pandémie
est très apprécié du public tunisien il
ya blaise et âme dit lily se sont rendus
dans deux festivals reportage
de la musique l'asie dans un
amphithéâtre romain qui date du 2e
siècle à el jem le festival est une
institution car il présente des
orchestres internationaux depuis plus de
30 ans et il fait vibrer les spectateurs
tunisiens qui découvrent d'autres
cultures musicales
j'adore à cause de la magie du lieu et
l'éclairage avec les bougies on écoute
de la musique classique seydoux sa
relaxe et ça fait oublier le stress du
quotidien
[Musique]
cette année le festival célèbre aussi de
jeunes talents tunisiens comme les
choristes du projet tunisia et i hate
qui vise à instaurer dans chaque collège
et lycée desclaude de
[Applaudissements]
ses choristes sont venus de toutes les
régions de la tunisie pour chanter des
paroles en hommage à la célébration de
la journée des droits de la femme dans
le pays comme fatma membre d'un club de
médenine ville au sud du 2 obama
c'est vraiment important pour des jeunes
comme moi d'avoir accès à de nouvelles
choses par exemple la musique classique
ce n'est pas forcément pas tous les
publics mais au moins on découvre
après les projections du soir en journée
les étudiants travaillent dans des
ateliers en plein air
une démarche basée sur un réseau de
bénévoles qui encourage les jeunes pas
seulement à produire des films on essaie
de former les jeunes les préparer pour
la vie
dans tous les sens l'engagement le
bénévolat
le travail collégial un apprentissage
pour affirmer sa créativité dans un pays
où la jeunesse très touchés par le
chômage et la crise économique a encore
besoin de rêver
voilà c'est la fin de journal de
l'afrique rester avec nous l'info
continue sur france 24
[Musique]